أنا دانا سانتوس مدرب للتنفس
والجسم الذهني في الرياضات الاحترافية
لأن آلام أسفل الظهر لها العديد من الأسباب ،
فلا يوجد حقًا رصاصة سحرية واحدة
من حيث التمرينات التي
ستحل آلام أسفل الظهر
ولكن
هناك مجموعة من العضلات تسمى
عضلات الفخذ لديك التي لها تأثير
على آلام أسفل الظهر ويمكن أن تساعد في
منعها وتخفيفها حتى تمر عضلات الفخذ
من هنا ومن الواضح أنها تشارك
في ثني الورك ، لذلك
عندما تجلس تنثني عضلات الفخذ
عند الجري  أو تقوم بالدوران أو التزلج ، فأنت
تستخدم أيضًا ثنيات الورك بحيث يمكن أن
تصبح مضغوطة وضيقة ،
وأثناء قيامهم بإمالة حوضك إلى الأمام مما
يضغط بعد ذلك على عمودك الفقري ويمكنك
الشعور بذلك في أسفل ظهرك ، لذا فإن هذا
التمرين مصمم ل  تساعد في تحرير
هذه العضلات لتمنحك الراحة
التي تحتاجها ولكن أيضًا ضع حوضك
في وضع أفضل لتجنب هذا
الضغط على أسفل ظهرك ، لذلك نبدأ
في وضع نصف ركوع وستحتاج
إلى وضع  إنني تحت ركبتك
لذا فقد ركبتي اليمنى لأسفل وقدمي
اليسرى للأمام
لذا ركبتي فوق كاحلي مباشرة
ثم ركبتي الخلفية أسفل فخذي مباشرة ،
ستضع يديك على
زفير
الوركين وارسم ضلوعك للداخل  للخلف وللأسفل ثم قم
بإمالة حوضك لأسفل حتى
تشعر وكأنك تحاول إمالة عظم الذنب لأسفل
وستشعر أنك تحصل على
تمدد من خلال الرباعية ومثنية الورك
هنا
، ثم أريدك أن تحافظ على ذلك لمدة
بعض الأنفاس تركز حقًا على تلك
الزفير الذي يحاول إمالة الحوض تحت
اليدين على
وركيك بعد أنفاس أو ثلاثة ، ستحافظ
على يدك اليسرى على وركك
وستأخذ ذراعك اليمنى وتنحني جانبيًا
لمدة اثنين أو ثلاثة آخرين  لا تفقد الأنفاس
هذا الميل الحوضي ، لذا لا تخرج منه
وابدأ في تنشيط عضلات الورك ،
فاحتفظ بها عن طريق إمالة
حوضك للأسفل
الآن ، ونريد أيضًا إخراجها على نطاق واسع
لأن الطريقة التي
تعمل بها عضلات الفخذ هي  هم ليسوا فقط
على التوالي هناك العديد  عدة عضلات تشارك
في ثني الورك ، لذلك من خلال اتخاذ
موقفك على نطاق أوسع ثم
تدوير الوركين خارجيًا ، لذا انظر كيف أحضرت
ساقي الخلفية هكذا وفتحت
فخذي بهذه الطريقة
التي ستعالج المزيد من الجزء
الخارجي من فخذك  أنت الآن بصدد
إمالة حوضك للأسفل مرة أخرى باستخدام
زفير ، ثم أريدك أن تذهب
مباشرة إلى هذا المنفذ الجانبي
الآن ، أمسك هذا لمدة مرتين أو ثلاثة
أنفاس أخرى
تشعر بالإفراج عن
الحفاظ على الوضع الذي تشعر به
قليلًا من الحرج قليلاً.
قد يكون التوازن غير مستقر بعض الشيء
، ولا بأس بذلك
فقط حاول أن تستقر وتتنفس
جيدًا ،
ثم
ستدور داخليًا بحيث تقوم
بالتدوير داخليًا وهذا يبدو محرجًا
للغاية وستشعر أن هذه الركبة تريد
السقوط فيها ، أحتاج منك أن تدفع  هذه الركبة
من أصابع القدم مستقيمة للأمام هنا
الضلوع أسفل الزفير
بعد
إمالة حوضك التي تميل فقط حوضك
هكذا ستشعر أن هذه الألوية تعمل لذا
تعمل مؤخرتك على هذا الجانب ولكن ثنائية  g
تمتد هنا
ثم يمينًا إلى ذلك الجانب الانحناء
[موسيقى
] وبمجرد الانتهاء من أنفاسك الثلاثة ،
يمكنك ممارسة التمارين الثلاثة
على الجانب الآخر وتبديل المنشفة
إلى الركبة
الأخرى ، ثم إذا وجدت أن هذا
يناسبك  لا يوجد سبب لعدم القيام بذلك
كل يوم كوسيلة للتخفيف
والوقاية من آلام أسفل الظهر